so the bite administration loses control
completely they get epiplectic and start
hyperventilating if you suggested really
the point of their immigration policy is
domestic politics maybe kind of
reshuffle the population a little bit so
they win they're not doing that now we
learn actually the bite administration
is secretly resettling foreign nationals
illegal immigrants all over the country
with resettlement flights most of them
secret
now almost 80 of these flights recently
have landed in the state of florida what
happened next well here's one thing an
illegal migrant from honduras called
medina uloa was on one of those flights
he is now accused of murdering a father
of four in his own home
ron desantis is the sitting governor of
florida he joins us tonight governor
thanks so much for coming on so
just the news stories suggest that the
administration was
sending planes into your state and
offloading people secretly from foreign
countries in violation of the law is
that
accurate so these are flights that are
coming in two or three in the morning uh
the feds of course control the airspace
and they're there on the ground uh they
take these folks and then they send them
in other parts of florida by bus or
other parts of the southeast and that
individual who was murdered was in fact
murdered by an illegal alien who was on
one of biden's flights these these
midnight flights unannounced no notice
no support for the state no ability for
us to veto it ahead of time and if if
biden had not been doing that if he'd
been doing his job that individual be
alive today
i i mean i i'm not a constitutional
scholar i know that you are an attorney
but are they allowed to do this can the
white house just decide you know we
don't we don't like you you may run for
president we don't like that and so
we're just going to flood your state
with people from other countries and
there's nothing you can do about it
so uh we're looking at what we can do i
think that they use these private
contractors so what we're looking at is
how can we fight back against the
contractors we can obviously deny them
state contracts which we will do
can we deny them access to florida's
market generally can we tax them can we
do things to provide disincentive so
they can't do it
so we're going to do whatever we can to
do it unfortunately
they do have the ability to get into
these airports because the faa controls
it and the feds really have jurisdiction
over it so we're trying to work with the
local airport authority see if there's a
way uh that we can get around that but
we are going to go after some of these
contractors because they are bringing in
people uh that are causing burdens on us
and as we see tragically uh cause
someone to lose their life
i bet you'll figure out a way governor
honda santos of the state of florida
appreciate you coming on tonight thank
you
thanks hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else